Jake Miller hat uns gefragt, wie wir
uns im Sommer kühl halten können.
Bitteschön: 6 Tipps.
*Titelmelodie*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Sonne, Hitze
und kein Schatten in Sicht -
hier sind 6 Science Tipps
zum cool bleiben.
1.: Hände weg vom Deo.
Was?
Iiiiihhhh!
Zumindest Hände weg
von Anti-Traspiranzien.
Die blockieren nämlich den Schweiß.
Schwitzen ist unsere effektivste
Maßnahme gegen überhitzen.
Beim Verdampfen des Schweiße
wird Verdampfungsenergie benötigt,
was in Form von Wärme abgezogen wird,
was wiederum
zu einer Abkühlung führt.
Stattdessen
reine Deodoranten benutzen.
Die lassen den Schweiß raus, sorgen
bloß dafür, dass er nicht stinkt.
Zur Funktion von Deos
habe ich schon mal ein Video gemacht,
das gibt es hier.
2.: die richtigen Klamotten.
Helle Klamotten sind gut,
da sie das Sonnenlicht reflektieren.
Aber auch
dunkle Kleidung funktioniert,
wie z.B. diese Beduinen
demonstrieren.
Schwarzer Stoff absorbiert
zwar mehr Sonnenlicht,
leitet die Wärme
aber auch schlechter weiter.
Wichtiger ist, dass viel Luft
an die Haut kommt,
damit der Schweiß
gut verdampfen kann.
Atmungsaktivität
ist wichtiger als Farbe.
3.: Finger weg
von Alkohol und Koffein.
Wer viel schwitzt, muss viel trinken.
Aber 'ne schöne Cola,
ein Eiskaffe oder ein kühles Bier
sind kontraproduktiv.
Sowohl Alkohol als auch Koffein
haben einen sog. diuretischen Effekt.
D.h., sie entwässern.
Auch dazu gibt es ein Video - hier.
4.: Heißgetränke.
Ja, kühle Getränke kühlen zwar,
heiße aber auch.
Die Körpertemperatur
steigt zwar minimal an,
doch der anschließende
Schweißausbruch
gleich das schnell aus.
Und kühlt den Körper sogar
noch ein bisschen mehr ab
als ein kühles Getränk.
5.: Verarsch dein Gehirn.
Minze enthält das Molekül Menthol.
Menthol aktiviert einen
Proteinrezeptor im Gehirn,
wodurch wir uns kühl fühlen,
selbst wenn wir es gar nicht sind.
Ein Pfefferminzbonbon
oder ein Wasserspray
mit ein paar Tropfen Minzöl
kann für gefühlte Kühle sorgen.
Aber Vorsicht,
das ist nur ein Notfalltrick.
Verarscht euren Körper
bloß nicht zu sehr.
Schließlich will er euch
etwas wichtiges sagen:
Ist ja gut.
In Chilis ist Capsaicin drin.
Das ist quasi
das Gegenteil von Menthol.
Es aktiviert Wärmerezeptoren, sodass
dein Gehirn glaubt, dir sei warm.
Die Folge ist schwitzen.
Was wiederum abkühlt.
D.h., du denkst dir sei heiß,
aber in Wirklichkeit
kühlst du durchs Schwitzen ab.
6.: Achtung Sonnencreme.
Immer schön eincremen,
gib Hautkrebs keine Chance.
Das blöde nur: Sonnencreme
beeinträchtigt das Schwitzen.
Also unser Kühlsystem.
Da hilft am Ende auch nur:
Sonne meiden.
Und, äh, bitte nicht nachmachen.
Also kein Schatten
hinter Autos suchen.
Bitte, lasst euch nicht überfahren.
Vielen Dank, Jake Miller.
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
dann schreibt sie in die Kommentare
und gleich kommen noch die Outtakes.
So und jetzt: ich trinke was und
schütt's mir dann voll ins Gesicht.
Ich mag gar kein Bier.
Sieht das nach Schweiß aus?
- Weiß ich nicht.
Kannst ja wirklich noch etwas laufen,
dann schwitzt du ja richtig.
*Klaviermusik*
Ich bin außer Atem,
aber ich schwitze noch nicht.
Egal, wir machen es mit dem Wasser.